Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Before we move on to the
Republican thing,
apparently apparently there's another Teetone video. Apparent
I've missed it, but there's another TeeOne video, guys. I never
got to the Techone video from yesterday. All right,
there's a te There's a Tech video. >> What's going on,
guys? >> That we've missed. All right. Oh, by the way,
just because some of you soy out about it, I've not been doing
all of the tech videos, okay? I've skipped a couple of them,
but this one is on Color Gate, so we're going to watch it. >> Hey,
what's going on, guys? It is
midnight, 1:00 a.m. Don't even know what day it is.
I just >> These people are pathetic. These people are really
pathetic. Like, are they are they as pathetic as, you know, crying
that somebody pointed out that your dad's assaulted multiple
women? If they as are they as pathetic as crying about that?
I don't know. Just got to the dragon trials and metaphor refantacio.
I think the game might actually break my top 10. Enjoying it
tremendously. I'm down two more pounds and I hit three new PRs
in the gym today, but I'm not going to say what those are because
I'm excited to show that whenever I get back. Um, today was a
lovely day. Went to the arcade,
spent more money than I should have,
as I often do. Twitter my ass off. Got a couple homies just be
dying at that [__] If I do it for them, you know,
I do it for the I do it for the West. I do it for the uh the
Nexes dog and treating animals videos. You never like my tweets.
It's always fun. Oh, the Nicholas Chibies. Great people. >> Regardless,
I was there. >> The Nicholases and the Chibies. Okay. Is
that the Hold on. I have to go through all the people he said
that just love his tweets. >> You know, I got I do it for
the West Jets. I do it for >> WestJet. The NX. I do it.
>> for the Sophia. The Shinyas, you know >> Sophia
Shina. I think Shina is definitely a uh a gotchi or sorry a gotcha.
Not gotchi. No. Although
uh gotcha streamer I think. I don't know >> read my tweets.
It's always fun. Oh the Nicholas the chibies
>> and Nicholas. I assume that's I don't know. And then
Chibby reviews.
Damn.
Sophia is his girlfriend, I think. >> great people. Regardless,
I was there thinking that the >> I can't wait. Can you
guys Aren't you guys excited for when like Chibi Reviews
All right, Chibi Reviews starts doing like um Tad Caf propaganda,
guys. It's Stop gooning, guys. Stop going. Stop going. Stop watching
anime. eight new Hassan clips that have resurfaced of him electrocuting
his dog and treating animals like would, you know, be sufficiently
covered in the video that I made a couple of days ago. Speaking
of which, thank you if you follow me on Twitter if you've seen
this. And thank you for subscribing me on YouTube. Uh, if you
are currently watching this, something happened a little bit
ago that I just kind of want to talk about and I want to kind
of just lay this structure out for those who don't know. And
what happened was this. Assan goes live and he uses an e-collar
on his dog. Now, I want to make this very clear, >> E-collars
can be used humanely, okay? They're supposed to feel like >> That's
not what you said on Twitter, by the way. Did he correct this
on Twitter when he said for using that collar, Hassan was like
a horrible monster who needs to be taken off uh Twitch, needs
to be permanently banned? >> Like a light touch to a firm
touch. I >> Oh, cuz he thinks he thinks the fact that Kaia
yelped means that it was horribly painful. That it was excruciatingly
painful and that's why Ka yelped. We'll see if he maintains that
that stance now knowing that it's incredibly when people use
them. I understand they can be used humanely. I've been very
consistent on this take. I have said this since day one. The
problem is you're supposed to use them shortterm. And by the
way, yes, I have talked to three now professional dog breeders
or sorry, dog trainers about this. In case you don't know, my
dog Mango is also being professionally trained. And they say
it is supposed to be a light touch to a firm touch as well as
shortterm
use only, maybe 15 to 30 minutes.
not have the electrocution so high it makes them scream in pain
and use it for 8 hours every >> scream in pain
>> and 8 hours a day
>> so that happened more of that is being developed every
single day feel free to follow my Twitter if you want to see
more of the updates because I'm making sure that Hassan will
be held accountable and we are >> okay that's it okay guys
somebody's got to take like OpenCV Open computer vision. Open
computer vision. And they've got to make a script that goes through
and one by one downloads each of the Hassan bods, maps out the
place where Kaia is and and just scrolls through frames until
Ka changes positions, like leaves the bed or or gets up. Okay,
this would be fairly easy to do. And then you got to run that
over all of his VODs for the past like 3 months. And you got
to see how long Kai usually lays there cuz I need the answer
to this question empirically at this point. Is OpenCV still relevant
with all the new AI junk? Well, you can run OpenCV on your own
computer. But like I just I want all that. Okay. I I just want
to know cuz I'm so tired cuz I looked and it seemed like 3 hours,
3 and a half hours was like around where Kai was leaving every
day, but everybody else says 8 hours. And I need to I need to
know empirically at this point. And I'm I'm getting close to
writing these scripts myself. Okay. I'm getting very >> You're
not going to move past this because him moving past this is how
he always wins. Just like he's gotten away with slandering me,
slandering my friends, and making people believe that everything
he says is gospel. when if you were to just look at it and research
it for 30 seconds or I don't know ask
everything that comes out of Assad's mouth is a steaming pile
of once again Assan if you're watching this I will give you $10,000
for your dog so that way it can go to a home that actually gives
a about it and I'll even donate $100,000
to animal charity if you give me your dog
moving forward also So, we should box moving forward. Valkyrie
ray.
>> Oh, that would be a good one. Hold on. That was to That
was to Hassan, right,
dude? That would actually be good. >> For some reason,
I wonder what the reason is, guys. Valkyrie Ray for some reason
just feels so strongly
about defending Hassan.
Wonder why that is.
and says that she has so much close personal experience with
heran. >> Is he is she acting like it's insider knowledge
to know that Valk Valkyrie and Hassan are dating? Is he acting
like he's about to reveal something crazy here like like it's
not something just everybody knows >> and he's she's seen
the dog and >> it's not they don't talk about it publicly
but it is public.
Uh, maybe. So, yeah. I don't I don't know if it'd be annoying
up to the ch Oh,
I see. So, you think she might be concerned or something? >> Sorry.
They can't hear you at all because of the directional mic. Right.
So, Okay. Okay. All right. >> And it's the most spoiled
baby. To quote her, big baby. Big fluffy baby that she's ever
seen.
Is she spoiled because she's allowed to walk around the house
when he's done streaming or does it >> Oh, sorry. Sorry.
The whole thing we were just discussing back and forth was whether
or not um it was public with uh Valkyrie and Hassan and that
they might not want it really referenced at all right now because
like Hassan's concerned about safety. If people know that Valkyrie
is his girlfriend, that could be like annoying for her at
right? that like they people could basically like it might become
a security risk for her if it was widely publicized for everybody.
>> Didn't Destiny leak that? No. I mean, we watch it on
stream. There's like what the OTV and Friends subreddit or something
that was posting videos of them like at some private wedding
together. Like they were there as as the each other's plus one
or something at some private wedding that wasn't there was no
stream at it. It was just some private person's wedding.
Is she spoiled because she's allowed to walk around the house
when he's done streaming? Or does a dog that gets crated for
10 hours wakes up and then has to sit in a box for 8 hours
and then maybe if Hassan isn't doing anything else, maybe he'll
>> Wait, is it He's just like making things up. Yeah, Hassan
clearly spends a ton of time with his dog.
Like a ton of time with his dog, I think. Dude, it's this is
kind of gross. This is kind of this is really gross, actually.
Like, by the way, just go and look. Did I miss some weird crate
lore? Well, maybe he maybe Ka sleeps in like a crate overnight
or something. I don't know. He says created for 10 hours. Maybe
there's some evidence Ka is created like after stream or something.
um or sorry to sleep like that. She's uh she's kennel trained.
>> He'll take it somewhere or knowing him a champagne socialist
will most likely hire some illegal immigrant which obviously
you know Hassan probably loves. Well, maybe he doesn't like him
so much considering his dog gets zapped every single time it
goes across the border. Maybe his stance on immigrants is still
on the fence. Maybe Ka will get a little bit of love every single
day. And I want to remind you, Ka is a 2-year-old working dog.
That is a working breed. They are a working [__]
breed. And that dog's exercise requirements is 2 and 1/2 2 and
1/2 to 3 hours a day of walking and then more play. Scientifically,
according to Assad's regiment, he's not meaning that even close.
The thing
>> why why is he saying this? Doesn't he take he takes
coyote every morning and then they go out again in the afternoon?
I thought I thought he explicitly hired a dog walker to come
at some point in the afternoon and take her out again. Like he
goes out with her every morning. He posts like videos of it and
then he hires somebody to come and take her out again for another
hourong walk. I thought that's already two right there. That's
2 hours of walking that that happened like every day. It seems
like thing is I'm so tired of streamers getting dogs to be used
for props and to be used as background set pieces and treating
these things like they're toys. It's the same thing with cats.
People think that cats should just be ignored all day. Bro, cats
aren't decorations. They're [__] animals. Play with
them. I talk to my cats. I play fetch with my cats. I call my
cat's name and they come because people are so out of touch with
reality with raising animals. They don't even know that cats
can also be taught tricks, too. It's really not hard if you just
give a [__] Now, Valkyrie,
for whatever reason, decides to defend Hassan and say that Hassan's
such a great guy and Kai is such a great guy. I don't know why
there's so many people worrying about this when there's a genocide
going on in Palestine. Oh my god, there's a genocide.
Jesus. I guess me losing a leg isn't so bad after all. >> Valky
Valkyrie really screwed up by just saying this. saying it at
all was stupid, but I again I just felt like you could ignore
it. Obviously, Technone's going to seize on it and signal over
it. >> I'm so tired of this.
>> Virtue signalers buzzword
promoters just saying I think the bad thing is bad. Guys, I think
p is bad.
Look at how much of a good person I am, guys. I think murder
I think it's bad. Oh my god. Shower me with praise.
Wow. No [__] We all understand that genocide is bad.
We get it. You don't you don't care. These people don't care.
The only thing they care about is being seen as a good person.
And when somebody tries very hard to be seen as a good person,
and this is going to be the moral of the video. Actually, no.
I'm not going to spoil it yet. People who try to be good people
are some of the most dangerous people that you can actually meet.
So,
What? Huh?
>> Are you saying, dude? What the?
>> Uh, I'm actually good because I don't try to be a good
person. I'm just like kind of And I don't really try to change.
And the people who try to be good people, okay, those are those
are the actual people. You're not just naturally good. Why don't
you just
>> uh I don't know. I >> I have no idea what this
is supposed to be. the people who try to be good
>> Well, Valkyrie gets into some heat. >> He should
He should probably at least I I assume he's meaning something
like the people who try to perform good people. The people who
are like performing that they're good, right? He's not meaning
try in like a real sense with acts and >> which deservedly
so. Deservedly so. She gets an E for that take. Uh want to make
this very clear. Um we're defending torturing dogs here. We're
defending a guy who's called for a senator. were defending a
guy. And none of these none of these are alleged, by the way.
I want to make this very clear. None of these are alleged. When
you look into this about me or other people, it's alleged. That
means somebody said it and so far there is nothing proving it
whatsoever.
When I talk about the things that Hassan has done,
I'm sorry, I heard foot >> you. So, he's he's going to
say that it's not alleged that Hassan tortures his dog. It's
just proven that Hassan tortures his dog because of the one clip.
Like, how do you not feel embarrassed if you have a follow on
this channel? How do you how do you rationalize that in your
own mind after watching something like this? Like, it's not proven.
It's not proven that I did anything. Okay, that's alleged. But
it is proven that Hassan did this to his I would I would feel
so embarrassed being subbed to this person and taking him seriously.
Like it's it's just embarrassing that he does this. And dude,
this guy is like like at least David was like skinny and cool
and attractive. This guy's like David but like
uh like disgusting ogre who spent the past like 6 years off to
lollip
like at least David was cool. This guy is just David but not
cool in any possible way.
It's very sad.
>> Steps had to deal with that real quick. When the things
I'm telling about Ham, none of these things are alleged. These
are real factual things that you can go watch him do.
He's called for the death of a senator.
He has self >> Didn't David sleep with a minor? I'm talking
about the aesthetics of the music like who he was as an influencer.
Obsidian. Yeah, obviously actual
not somebody I love, but I'm saying that like the the aesthetics
of following them when you don't know about the crimes. Obviously,
like I could understand somebody following David. I can't understand
anybody following Techone. It's just crazy. I don't understand
people who would follow David now after he's shown to be a right
now. It should be over for him. >> Admitted to going to
a diddy party. He has attended a brothel with at least one child
present. By the way, in case you don't know what a brothel >> with
at least one child present, like he's just lying. He's He's literally
just lying completely.
It's just a bunch of lies. The brothel thing. Um the German government
had to apologize to them for the raid, right? They weren't they
weren't found guilty of anything. It was like suspected of human
trafficking. They found no evidence. The the German government
had to apologize. And instead of saying they were raided for
human trafficking, which would be the truth and still misleading,
he actually just makes up that there was a child present. Like
he went to a brothel with a child present.
I don't think he's lying. No, he's he Trust me, he's had himself
corrected enough times, Matt Enalt, that this is just objectively
lying. We should just go We should go rewatch the uh the Dan
Saltman, Nuxtaku, Techone
stream again, and just watch Dan tell him like, "No, no, no.
The way you deal with Han is you just lie about him like with
no remorse whatsoever cuz they'll lie about you." What was the
other one he just did here? He did the the brothel and then the
I >> He's called for the death of a senator. >> Called
for the death of a senator. >> Self admitted to going to
a diddy party. >> Oh, the diddy party. Yeah, the diddy
party where like
>> uh the diddy party where there's like a video with a
little girl on it that made him uncomfortable so he left. >> Yeah,
that that diddy party. >> He has attended a brothel >> that
was at Coachella I think. So he's at Coachella. They had like
some tent that where they were having like what they called the
diddy party. He saw some video playing was like, "Oh, that's
weird. I'm going to go
>> with at least one child present." By the way, in case
you don't know, >> why don't you just talk about the terrorist
stuff? Like, that's reasonable and true. You could totally hate
Hassan for his for his takes on foreign policy. That's reasonable
to hate Hassan for that. That's okay. Just you don't have to
make all the things up. Just say the things that are true and
then it's like reasonable to think he's a total loser for those
things. That's fine. >> Know what a brothel is? It's a
where >> uh they did not find a child at the brothel though.
Easy. That's the thing. That's like a That's just lying. >> They
had kids at it. This isn't alleged. These are things that happened.
Okay. He has told people to kill their landlord. >> They
did it. They did at a different point. Not in the raid. Okay.
Okay. Okay. I got it. >> And let the the the [__]
roads run red with their capitalist blood. He has informed his
audience on how to make death threats to people who are higher
up to get them to step down from their political position. These
aren't alleged
>> Does he think Does he think the Tom Cotton tweet was
doing this? Does he think the Rick Scott thing was doing >> These
are real things. This man is out of control. You look into the
things that Hassan says or the people who oppose him, none of
it is real.
He blows [__] out of proportion. None of it ising
real. It's things that he has made up or chosen intentionally
to weaponize.
That's all it is.
I saw a Twitter post about me today with 300 likes in about 2
hours saying that I don't want to trust Tech because this guy
beat his wife. >> Dude, there's just this is just Ethan
Klein all over again, isn't it? This is the same thing as Ethan
Klein where it's like I'm going to lie and make a whole bunch
of things up about you, right? I'm going to say a whole bunch
of things that aren't true and then when somebody lies about
me, when somebody makes something up about me that's like adjacent
to the truth in the in the exact same way,
I'm going to lose my I don't I just don't get how can you be
so sensitive and do this stuff. >> I don't know what realm
of these
are hallucinating that I did this. There's no clip of it. I don't
even think there's anybody even saying that. >> I am the
conflict resolution. >> They believe it so hard because
Hassan paints me and many other people as such horrific human
beings that they become myself as well become dehumanized and
people are willing to believe anything whatsoever generally because
they believe with Hassan's political views which is I'm pro Palestine.
Aren't I a really good guy? Have you seen my bio? I have a Palestine
flag.
Jesus
get a grip.
So Valkyrie Ray reaches out to Aszmigold and NMP lol. I don't
know why she reached out to NMP. I don't know what she was expecting.
NMP I mean I mean he is himself admitted a a complete fence sitter.
I don't know if she was expecting some way to navigate drama.
I mean Nope is getting
you know what I mean?
>> Yeah. She was basically like oh here are the guys who
I think like get a lot of controversy
um and don't go don't lose their minds. How do I handle it? That's
Well, NMP kind of loses his mind. I have no idea why Valkyrie
asked NMP. NMP doesn't handle it well on either side. He doesn't
handle the the talking well. Like, he's he's not good at like
absorbing it. And he's also not good at like handling or responding.
He's bad at every single part of it. Messaging Asminold makes
some sense. Okay. Asminold, this stuff blows off his back like
water off a duck. >> Expecting some way to navigate drama.
I mean, NFP is going to on 24 [__] >> Well,
sure. Maybe maybe if she thinks if she believes that NMP could
get, you know, stale to to remove something for him. That makes
sense. >> You know what I mean? >> Sorry. Remove
something for her. >> Don't know what advice he would have
offered, but that's besides the point. She reaches out to Asmin
and asked for his help to navigate the drama that she's going
on in her time of need. She reached out to an old friend to get
some advice. And Asmin helped, no questions asked. Took time
out of his day to make sure she was okay. Now, how do you think
she repays that? She repays that by the next day when her community
says, "How dare you talk?" >> Oh, I thought,
"Oh, I she does do this." And this is like This is kind of stupid.
this was dumb when she like was like, "Oh, I apologize for messaging
Asmin Gold to ask him for help."
>> she is like she is like that. Remember when she got
really uh she she like apologized to her community for saying
what? No cap on a stack. Didn't she apologize for that, too?
Yeah. >> Likely because they're a bunch of Hassan heads
uh or otherwise what I like to call um complete.
She bends the knee and apologizes
for
even talking to Asmin Gold and affirms that he is just as
everybody says he is to where he shouldn't even be talked to.
This is what they do.
Wait, by apologizing she did that? I'm trying to I'm trying to
make sense of his argument here. Hold on. Let me let me find
this tweet
without
Ray. Let me find this tweet really quickly.
Apologizes to our community for DMing Asmin Gold. Let's just
watch this >> the day. It is my fault for not being >> So,
I would expect her to say, "Okay, I get that you guys don't want
me to talk to Asmin Gold or whatever, but he was very helpful."
I think she should probably go and say, "He was super helpful
to me." So, I understand that you guys don't want me to talk
to him. I understand that that was maybe jarring for you to know
that I associate with him, but uh as long as she didn't throw
him under the bus, I don't think she did something wrong here.
We'll see. >> At the end of the day, it is my fault for
not being aware enough. And I apologize to my community. It was
probably so hurtful
um and so jarring. I'm not I'm under a rock and that's my fault.
So, I think everyone, including myself, should be more aware
of >> Oh, this is cut off. [__] >> what's
going on in the world and what people are saying. I I just like
it is my fault at the end of the day. That is my fault. Literally
no one's fault but my own. >> How did this get out? Because
she said to her chat that she asked Asmin Gold and NMP for help.
>> I'm not aware enough. And that's on me. You're a good
role model till this point. I I don't think so. >> That's
freedom. I believe she is saying that it was hurtful to her audience
to engage with Asmin Gold and then tell them about it which like
okay if that's the if that's the audience you want the people
who are going to get upset unless you say that. >> I don't
think I am. I think I I >> I do think this is a little
weird isn't it? Like do you not think Hassan would feel a little
weird about this too? Hey guy who's most farming my boyfriend's
downfall. Could you give me some ideas for how to navigate my
poor handling of my boyfriend's downfall? It's It's like a little
Maybe it could work. I don't know. I feel like wouldn't Hassan
feel strange about that? >> I think I have a good job of
recognizing when I do mess up and accepting that and being okay
with it. But and it's all good. It's all like I I hear you guys.
I see you guys. >> Dude, could you imagine? She's like,
"Hey, I I had some controversy." So, I messaged the people I
know who deal with controversy a lot. Um, Asmin Gold, Ethan Klein,
and Destiny, and ask them for
>> You're right.
You're so right.
And it is 100,000% my fault for not being aware enough.
And I need to be I need to be
more proactive in being aware of people and what's going on in
this world. Listen
guys, even when it's happening to me, it is a thousand% okay
to hold people accountable for
actions and mistakes. Okay.
Um I think that the biggest discourse is seeing like I feel like
the community is split. Like some people are being too harsh,
some people are not being harsh enough. And it's like it's like
I see I see you. I see you. Okay. It is it is a good thing. And
because because of that I was able to do like a deep dive. I
was able to leave my rock and see and be more aware of it. And
um you know,
>> I just straight up don't believe for a millisecond that
Hassan doesn't talk her ear off about Asam Gold. I'm sorry. This
is like I hate to just call her a liar like this, but I'm going
to call her a liar. Okay. There's no chance you spend any significant
amount of time with Assad and he doesn't bring up how much of
an Asthmold is on a regular basis.
I I don't believe it. I don't believe it at all. Has she said
anything so far that wasn't just PR? That wasn't just PR. No.
No.
I I don't believe that. No. Verain, you are coping so hard. If
you think that he doesn't mention Asmin Gold's free time, you're
crazy.
Hassan is so into the drama stuff. He's so into knowing all of
this stuff all the time. He absolutely would have brought this
up 100% >> and be more aware of it. And um you know I I
need to I need to be more aware.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Cy, I don't think it doesn't
seem like she on Asmin Gold. She's just like, "Oh, I didn't know
why people would be mad about me going after or going to talk
to Asmin Gold." Now I get it. Um that's my bad if you guys are
upset about it, but it's my
I don't know. I think uh I think that's fine. I don't see that
as her like implying it's okay to just totally or I don't think
she on Asmin Gold there. Valkyrie is spineless.
Uh,
>> I think things got to change out here, man. There's
got to be there's like a paradigm shift coming, okay? Where it's
not just like there has to be a paradigm shift coming just in
terms of like a lot of YouTube comment. I understand a lot of
YouTube commentary where it's like, I'm just going to sell you
the the the nice content pieces of like the people you hate.
I'm going to tell you how you can hate them more. There has to
be like a shift back to something. There there has to be some
kind of like
swap back to oh, we're not going to do this anymore. I think
I hope I pray
that's been YouTube forever. Okay.
>> All right. Talking to Asmin Gold and affirms that he
is >> Why? Why would that ever change? I just feel like
there's so many people doing it and there's like such a push,
you know? Uh you know what? Actually, it wouldn't change because
realistically the comparable for people's like media um media
diets is Trump, right? And I would something would have to change
with Trump. People would have to stop like believing in Trump.
Trump would have to stop winning with like the exact like super
one-sided hatred he produces,
right? I'd have to see something change there for me to expect
anything to change with YouTube cuz I feel like this is just
a bunch of people engaging in the exact same strategy where they're
never going to admit any faults on their side. They're just going
to go after the people they hate all the time. >> Just
as
everybody says he is to where he shouldn't even be talked to.
This is what they do.
They label >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. I need to go back >> dare
you talk to Asagle. Most likely because they're a bunch of Hassan
heads. uh or otherwise what I like to call um complete [__]
reason. She bends the knee and apologizes
>> Oh, I didn't see I didn't see this manic gank. If I
just copy my bad talking to Asmin Gold and affirms that he is
just as
everybody says he is to where he shouldn't even be talked to.
This is
>> I feel like it was different than that. I feel like
it was more of like a I understand why you guys would be upset
and it is what it is, right? Like I I shouldn't have done that.
I think she she basically it seemed like she tried to go out
of her way to say don't go after Asmin Gold. It's not Asmin Gold's
fault. I I [__] up doing this. I understand why you
guys would be upset. >> This is what they do.
They label you as a inhuman monster who's not even okay to be
communicated with. Acting like Asminold is a level 80 warlock
who's going to put seed of corruption on you and put a dot on
you and all of your community and farm you all like a frost mage
in vanilla World of Warcraft.
It is
Did any of that make sense? Hold on. Do we have to do we have
to put the the wow hat back on and just like call him out for
being totally performative here? Hold on.
>> They label you as a inhuman monster who's not even okay
to be communicated with acting like Asthma Gold is a level 80
warlock.
level 80 warlock seed of corruption on you and put a dot on you
and all of your community and farm you all like a frost mage
in vanilla World of Warcraft.
>> Frost mages aren't known for farming
uh seed of corruption. I guess seed of corruption is a thing.
Um is seed of corruption Hold on. Is seed of corruption even
a thing in vanilla? Hold on. Hold on. I need to see the icon
for seed of corruption to know. No, seed of corruption has to
be BC, right? TBC. Seed of corruption has to be TBC. No, he's
saying vanilla, but I thought he said vanilla. >> Who's
going to put seed of corruption on you and put a dot on you and
all of your community and farm you all like a frost mage in vanilla
World of Warcraft.
It is said level 80 Warlock and now Oh, level 80 Warlock. Okay,
sure, sure, sure.
Okay, that applies something else. Okay, fair enough. But then
vanilla World of Warcraft there at the end. I was just like,
okay, I >> whatever. King outrageous.
And I want to let you know, is there going to be some big drama
between Asthma and Valkyrie from this? No. I don't know if you
guys remember this. I know a lot of people like to refer to me
as a asthma gold light, which doesn't bother me at all, by the
way. I'm just happy to be in the same sentence as my friend.
Um, it's flattering. I think Asmin's a great guy. I was the guy
who was on Hassan before a lot of people were [__]
on Hassan for the recent deeds that he did when crossing Asmin.
And the reason why that is is because Asmin really doesn't like
dealing with that type of drama. He doesn't.
He's too reasonable sometimes. And I don't know what that is.
People want to act like he's a farright N. I'll be real, bro.
Asmin's a liberal. I mean, you know what I mean? He's he's a
he's a Okay. He's a >> Asicole is just like Charlie Kirk.
Okay. He's like super liberal, super moderate. He's very much
like Charlie Kirk in like so many ways. Basically a liberal.
Yeah. Basically a liberal. >> Leftle leaning centrist.
Let's just call it as a >> like Asminold doesn't even advocate
for death camps against any race. That's basically that's just
liberals. Okay. If you're not advocating for death camps, you're
a liberal. There I said it. All right. Those >> He's going
to go live and I'm going to make sure this video goes out before
he streams. I'm going to predict the
Because this is what he does every time. He's going to go live.
He's going to see what Valkyrie Ray said and he's going to say,
"That's okay. I understand why she had to do that. No hard feelings
on my whole soul.
I know that's what's going to happen because that's what happens
every time."
>> And that's not hard to predict. Yeah. Asmin Gold never
goes after anybody for like saying bad things about him because
he knows it's not worth it, right?
That's not That's not difficult to predict. That doesn't mean
you're a good person. That could easily be a calculus a bad person
could do.
>> Doesn't mean you're a good person. Although I don't
think Asmin Gold's like I think Asminold's more bad in that he's
made some calculations that he's going to make certain money
sh uh like shilling certain opinions.
None of his interpersonal stuff has ever seemed like bad to me.
He seems like interpersonally very capable for a person who's
like got that many psych issues that he can't go outside and
>> these people treat him like he's a monster when in reality
he is one of the most downto- earthth kind individuals I have
ever met and I have a lot of respect for this for this guy. Now
once again, Asmin's not a guy I frequently
>> I I don't know why people do this, right? Like I understand
that somebody you could have Asmin Gold is operating in politics.
People aren't calling Asmin Gold a bad person
in politics for any reason other than his political opinions
and the crowd that he like rolls with, right? That's why they
call him a bad person. His interpersonal dynamics, his interpersonal
charisma has nothing to do with whether or not people call him
a bad person for how he operates in the political sphere. So
he could be the nicest human being who has the closest personal
relationships, who takes care of his family and still advocates
for stoning black people to death for no reason, right? He doesn't
do that. But I'm saying that those two things could be put together.
You can't totally disconnect what he says in the realm of politics
from from all the stuff that he does and like who he is as a
person, right? And he did just, you know, totally lean into the
separating kids from their families regardless of if they had
entered the country and hadn't done anything wrong in like a
decade, right? No, no, no. I was just I was trying to pick something
Sophia's intentionally offensive, right? Like to to drive home
the point like he could be advocating for horrible things and
still be very nice interpersonally. your interpersonal dynamics
with him have nothing to do with why people say he's a bad person.
And by the way, as apparently Asmigold's dad and Asminold himself
have both acknowledged that he deals in a lot of hatred. He sells
a lot of hatred on the internet right
now. I I don't I'm not using that as like his dad to use his
dad's word against him. I'm saying he's accepted this in the
past, too.
So, we're we're like trying to disconnect things and say he's
a really good person interpersonally. I think that's like fine,
but for me, I don't give a that Donald Trump was really charismatic
and cool with Bill Maher right at dinner. Hey, Donald Trump's
advocating for and like ripping up your advocating for like a
fascist state. He's like trying to push presidential authority
to its absolute maximum. And essentially, it looks like overcome
the entire democratic process
>> to like override it.
Not a good person. And it doesn't matter how nice he is to Bill
Maher at dinner. that it doesn't matter at all.
>> It's just so weird that they do this comparison of like,
well, he's really nice to me, guys. He like totally pet my dog.
Yeah, that's what people said about
totally love dogs, guys. At least he love dogs. You ever hear
that? It's not, oh, love dogs, so the Holocaust thing wasn't
so bad. No, nobody says it that
>> Hang out with chumming it up on the weekends.
He's a great guy who I had a very good relationship with. >> Also,
I need two seconds of water. We we weren't we weren't dating.
We we did a podcast together. We were or together and we would
talk, right? Great guy. I'm not defending this guy because I
consider him a friend. I'm defending this guy because it's the
right thing to do because he hasn't done anything
Like, and I'll be real, all of the things that people have pretended
Asmin have done has either one, not even that bad, or two, completely
made the up. Now, I'm sure whatever left-leaning Hassan dicks
sucker who's going to react to this and say, "Well, actually,
did you hear about this one thing?" Shut the up. Okay. Yeah.
to to all the gay people that got really upset about, you know,
what Asmin Gold said about those other countries, why don't you
go to those countries uh and watch them as they behead you? Continue
to have the LGBTQ flag in your bio and support countries that
would [__] you in the head if you were to step into
their country for just being gay. Uh have fun, I guess. Well,
welcome back to reality, guys. Moral of the story is never defend
the weak. Do not. We should have known because Valkyrie Ray apologized
for saying no cap on a stack for real for real. And when the
black community said, "Oh, actually that's AAVN. That's African-American
vernacular." And you will not be using that, man. >> I
went to the bathroom at the worst possible time. Me. Uh, hello.
I'm back. Okay, we have to go through a couple of these things.
All right, let me go back. >> Like, and I'll be real. I
had to comment on a couple of these things and we're going to
we're going to go through >> all of the things that people
have pretended Asmin have done is either one not even that bad
or two completely made the [__] up. Now I'm sure
whatever >> uh I don't think Asminold is actually like
bad in any Asminold's like a he's like a slow burn. All right.
He's like running defense. He's equivocating the actions of he's
equivocating for the actions of an administration that's basically
like ripping up your constitution, right? Like he is he's constantly
going, "Oh yeah, but you know this other thing happened. Oh yeah,
this is not so bad. Oh, all these people lie and like try to
try to gain as much power as possible. They're just mad that
Trump's doing it well, right?" Like he'll do like that, which
I'll admit as each of those individual acts are not really that
big a deal probably, but I would say over time they lead to,
oh well, he's really normalizing a thing that's incredibly harmful.
in my opinion. So, it's not like I have an individual thing he
said that's so bad. He seems like quite calculated and quite
controlled in a lot of instances and how he does the the kind
of propaganda that he does.
Yeah. So, like I I don't know why he would expect oh we have
to have some really bad thing as gold said that's I don't think
that really exists except I guess the Palestine thing which we'll
get to in just lefting Hassan [__] who's going to
react to this and say well actually did you hear about this one
thing? Shut the up. Okay. Yeah. To to all the gay people that
got really upset about, you know, what Asminold said about those
other countries, why don't you go to those countries uh and watch
them as they behead you? Continue to have the LGBTQ flag in your
bio and support countries you
>> uh so I don't know why. What what are people advocating
for those countries to do? Are they advocating for that country
to be able to stone gays to death? Or are they advocating for
those countries to not live under like an apartheid and not be
like for no reason? To not be a child in those countries, not
just get like hit with a a missile and just be declared collateral
damage. Like that's what they're arguing for, right? They're
not arguing for like, oh, hey, actually these people should get
to, you know, stone gaze to death. They should be able to throw
them off of roofs. Nobody says that. Why Why would you act like
that?
That's why Aspen Gold admitted that his comment was ignorant,
right? Cuz he went, "Yeah, I get it." Like, "Oh, probably we
don't need, you know, kids getting killed because their parents
believe bad things." That's probably not something I should have
said. And I kind of did say that through my words. And that was
wrong. That's why Asmin Gold did that if you were to enter their
country for just being gay. Uh, have fun, I guess. Well, welcome
back to reality, guys. Moral of the story is never defend the
weak. Do not. We should have known because Valkyrie apologized
for saying no cap on a stack for real. For real.
That was also cringe. Yes, that was also >> And when the
black community said, "Oh, actually that's AAVN. That's African-American
vernacular." And you will not be using that, ma'am. Roshi apologized
for that. Do not help these people because the only people they
want to help is themselves. They look to you for comfort. They
look to you for aid, but if they can get that by stabbing you
in the back, they will be the first to do so. A army of weak
soldiers will be the first ones to drive their spears into their
back. I genuinely feel like Asminold's going to watch the Valkyrie
video and go, "Oh man, that sucks that you got to do that." He's
going to like feel bad for her. I bet he's going to literally
just be like, "Oh, she shouldn't have done that. She shouldn't
have said she's associated with me." Almost almost guaranteed
>> need self-preservation. I don't want to >> We
got video experienced hardship who haven't overcome hardship
by their own means because I understand if they experience hardship
and it can be solved by me over, they're going to do it. And
I'm just going to be completely real. the amount of people who
have used me as a scapegoat in my life. >> And I'm sure
you can probably name five right now. I'm done being the >> He's
like he's like so performatively angry for Asmin Gold. Okay.
Like he is
This is like the people who get really mad over and they're like,
"No, you it denigrates a whole group of people." And it's like,
"Yeah, but the the [__] people don't know. Like they
don't get it, right? They don't really get it." And he's like
those people. He's like way more angry than the actual group
that they're referring to. He's he's like so upset on Asmin Gold's
behalf. Asmin Gold is just going to be like, "Nah, it's not that
big a deal." And move on. It's just kind of cringe, right? Like
why are you way more Why are you way more upset than anyone else?
I don't understand why. >> Scapegoat for weak people. >> And
that's like I've noticed that coming up around Asmin Gold is
he's got all these people who will get so offended on his behalf
for anything somebody says about him. and he sits there and he's
like, "Yeah, I don't really care. >> I'm done AoE taunting
for weak people because I know >> I guess that's that's
reinforcing the idea that there would be a market there, right?
Cuz the audience obviously wants to see him defended, right?
Asmin Gold's audience wants Asminold defended. So there would
be like a splinter audience, right? There'd be like a splinter
audience of people who would go and they'd be like, "Oh, I can
go watch Teone and he'll defend Asmin Gold. I can go watch Knucks
and he'll defend Asmin Gold. I can go watch apparently Chibi
Chibi reviews and he'll defend Asma Gold. I don't know. >> No,
they will not repay me with the same kindness because they can't
talk about me publicly. What? They'll DM me all day. If standing
by your values is what's going to cost you everything, maybe
those things that you're defending aren't really worth keeping.
I think it's time we really take a good hard look in the mirror,
reflect upon ourselves, and understand during hardship, will
you fight or will you fold? The weak have ruled the internet
for far too long. Liars, manipulators, virtue signalers have
ruled the internet for far too long because these communities
can get really angry and throw a temper tantrum and say we won't
sub or we'll telling your sponsors. I'm good. I will do everything
in my power to say what we're all thinking. And I'll be real.
You go to my Twitter, you will see a guy who's saying this. Dude,
the way he acts like I I just see all I can see now is David
that he's like he thinks he's like this totally tortured artist
who's like getting betrayed by everybody around him. He can't
see a single thing he does wrong. This I I don't think this vacation's
been helpful for him at all. Uh man, it's this is >> That
we're all thinking yet for some reason people don't want to say
yet. Not to jerk me off. I'm probably showing plenty flask. I've
already came like four times today. You know what dick damage
is? I've come so much. much. I have like this hardened vein on
my [__] My incredibly
average [__] by the way. Yeah. I wonder what it's
like having a huge I wonder if you get a headache cuz you lose
so much bloating at home. Anyways, it gets the job done and I'm
happy with it. And it curves a little bit. It's fun. Maybe it's
cuz I always talk to them at belt loop at school because Mr.
Streer would call me up and I would always >> Okay, I think
I'm uh probably just done with this. I think uh
I think we're we're good. We're good. We're good. We're good.
We're good. There's no way. There's like 20 seconds left. There's
nothing There's nothing possible here for something that's relevant.
Okay.
Gh.
Why did nobody tell me that that's where that was going me?
Gross. Internet versus collargate. Multiple shocks. Hold on.
Might have to check this out, too. But for now, I was going to
actually switch over to the Asmin Gold video. I just want to
see as gold's reaction to whatever the Valkyrie situation was.
See if there's anything interesting there.
>> It's crazy that this has thing has been going on for
a week now and it's still getting worse. Like it was already
>> Wait, who who the is he talking about? Wait, who or
sorry, who is he talking to here? Not who's he talking about.
Who's he talking to? I don't recognize the >> Bad. Horrible.
And it's still getting worse. Meanwhile, his community is still
running defense for him. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
He's watching a video. He doesn't talk to other people. He's
watching a video. No, no, no, no, no. He's watching a video.
He doesn't talk to other human beings. It sounded like he was
talking to somebody who's a human being, but he he he's just
talking to himself. Okay. Okay. Good.
Good. Good.
Hold on.
>> Imagining Tectton's ex-wife wondering what he's Oh,
hold on. Hold on. What is this? That it's like adult only. How
many calories do you think is in
Hey, liberal. How many calories you think is in Hassan's gun?
Okay. All right. Yeah, we're not on the internet versus video.
We're going this guy. >> Everyone else is the problem.
Another Twitch streamer. >> I think it's going to be pretty
hard to uh to run defense for it at this point. I really think
so. It's just like it's so obvious, isn't it? It's so obvious
>> has also come out making a statement defense for Hassan.
>> And Valkyrie, who was defending him a few days ago and
got a bunch of backlash for her terrible take. Well, she went
to Asmin Gold and asked Gold for advice. Asmin kindly and generously
gave her advice and then what does she do? She turns around and
throws the guy under the bus. Now, if you saw my video yesterday,
you remember if you watched like the whole thing cuz near the
end of it, I specifically showed how like Valkyrie was getting
a ton of heat from her chat when she >> Oh, yeah. Messaging
me never respond. As never go to that. Why would you message
him? Bad idea, bro. They were not happy about as Oh my god. No.
No. Not him. No. They were so upset about it. I mean, she should
have known to be honest. She should have known that. I mean,
really, she should have known. Like, I told you like there's
no way like the way that people like that think. You have to
understand that like if you you create cuz like she's apologized.
Like I mean, I like Ray. I mean, that's why I helped her, right?
But like the fact is that like she's apologized and cultivated
a community of people that are they're extremely controlling.
They are hyper sensitive and they constantly want her to be a
>> It just seems like No, it just seems like he's gonna
understand completely. >> They don't even want her to be
a person in a way. They want her to be a like a a character.
And I I I think that's very unhealthy. And and if you you not
necessarily her fault, but I think that like being that type
of a person is very unhealthy. It there's people are not like
that. It's like if you're really if if you're at the point in
your life where you're getting upset at a person for asking another
person for advice, you you've lost the plot. I mean, you're you're
totally off the rails. And and I think that Rey, I mean, I remember
she apologized for using like a AAV. And people might not know
what this this means. It's a AAV is >> AfricanAmerican
vernacular English, African-Amean vernacular English which means
like there were like terms like for real for real like uh I'm
finaguno like that right like >> uh can you no he didn't
say she was responsible she he I think he literally like sidestepped
that there like he didn't actually say it that that intentionally
he said um said like not intentionally she didn't intentionally
do it but she has the kind of community that's been cultivated
this way that they expect her not to be a person >> just
basically I mean I I hate to say it cuz it sounds like very crass
and like you know borderline racist basically you know stuff
that black people kind of say right and for show yeah exactly
like basically and she went and apologized for this and I I think
that like really she should have never done that and in in in
apologizing for that I think that you enable people that are
like this that will become increasingly more controlling over
time and as they become more controlling the space that you're
allowed to exist in becomes smaller and smaller because I think
that communities like that and I think this is true with also
like a different social movements etc. They are kind of self-radicalizing
and basically there are like purity tests that become it's like
a Russian nesting doll of purity test. I don't think this is
like wrong. I do think that like when your community tells you
you have to apologize for something you immediately go do it.
You are building like every time you reaffirm that behavior.
Like it's almost better to just let your community know you can't
be like blackmailed by them. It doesn't mean you should totally
push back against it but you need to have like a good idea of
how many people are there,
Like it doesn't mean you totally ignore any criticism.
There's like a fine line there I think and eventually you know
something happens where you know part of the people are happy
the other part are not happy. And I think that if you constantly
apologize for expressing yourself in different ways you run into
two problems. You run into the first problem is that people don't
think that you're authentic. And the second problem that you
run into is that people think that you are uh you know like basically
you're a bad person. So they either hate you for doing it or
they hate you for apologizing. The only thing they have in common
is that they hate you. And that's basically what happens. And
you you can see messages like this and like the allowing yourself
to be like micromanaged and controlled by your fans is is I think
a very very bad idea for being like a longtime content creator
like long-term content creator. Now obviously like you know it's
it's not like you can't do that at all. But I don't think it's
also very fulfilling either because you can't I think in some
cases probably you know these people would never admit to this
right at least publicly. But you probably can't do things or,
you know, express yourself in ways that you might really feel
because it would maybe go against that type of community. And
I think that again, >> like nothing's wrong here, but it's
like honestly I feel like we could all basically give this exact
take in our sleep, right? Like everybody could see it. He's not
wrong. I just wanted to confirm that he probably wasn't even
angry. If anything, you like felt a little bit bad for her. And
it just leans directionally towards like what I was saying. Yeah.
It just leans directly towards my my thinking. So, I don't know.
I didn't need anything more out of this from Asmin Gold. I was
just I was just looking to see.
Okay. All right,
man. Where are we going after this? Oh, there's a couple things
I wanted to do, but I think that's that's basically it. Look,
look, I think we could probably keep doing Color Gate forever,
right? Like, do we want to just keep doing Color Gate? Oh, Zog
Time. Yeah. Oh, dude, I could do I could just go around through
all of the opinions on this. I see a Hutch video, 19,000 views
from yesterday about about this.
Denim's struggling to keep up with Hassan's lies.
Is this really going to be what this is? Is this You guys want
to just go down? You guys just want to go down this uh this human
centipede? This collargate human centipede the whole time? People
are like, "No, no." And yet, if I were to do it, I know the views
would just continue to go up up up up forever. I know. I know
they would. The whole time they would always just go up. Okay,
hold on a second. Uh let's see here.
Can I do this? Apparently all the comments about Nicholas Dioro
not knowing. Wait, what? How did the time stamp not work here?
What?
>> Can I get my time stamp working?
>> For a while, I felt like if I changed my content over
time that people would tear >> Eat the dog. Eat the Zogchow.
I got to Google what Zogchow actually is. I've been saying it
a lot. All right, guys. I'm [__] done. So the whole
concept here, if you guys are missing it, all right, is Nicholas
Dio doesn't know what Zog is, which is just kind of funny given
how much of his commentary skews political, right? How he like
defends Israel, defends, you know, people's comments on Israel,
but he doesn't know what Zog is. So this is January 2025 is 9
months ago.
Hold on, another one.
>> People, and they were going on and on about a lot of
miseducation around dwarfism in general. So I was like, "Oh my
god, this is the perfect time to educate people." >> Oh,
hold on. Hold on. This I I missed a clip. I missed a clip. I
missed a clip. >> I genuinely just wish there was a lot
>> Nick, the H3 snark subreddit is going to clip you saying
Zogchow. Is there something wrong with Zogchow? Is it like Goonar
coded? Am I going to get in trouble? What is Does anyone know
what that means? >> Positivity out there. And the clips
that would get views would be the ones where I'm actually responding
positively and giving people challenges, being nice, and shout,
"Oh, trust me. I know that there's a clip with him being uh confused
about Jreg's video that he really thought that Progressive Victory
was going to canvas against somebody called Zogs and thank yous,
but nobody cares about that. All I ask is that you just understand
there's always two sides to every story. I'm not going to make
any more videos covering this. I want to just focus on the positive
because again, you focus on the positives. >> Ironically,
being British should literally be considered hate speech >> and
to create a more positive community. This kind of stuff does
not make me feel good. It's just not very fun. >> It's
racist. Why?
What is this? Uh, no. I didn't see this cringe on main. I don't
I don't know if he would have said that. Um, maybe he gets really
mad about me. I unfortunately he's got me blocked on everything,
so I don't really think about him at all. I I kind of can't.
>> Z. I thought Zog was a former commentary YouTuber who
was featured in several Turkey Tom videos who had a yellow >> And
it just makes you >> who was featured in several Turkey
Tom videos who had a yellow avatar. >> And it just makes
you not excited to stream. It doesn't make you excited to make
videos and everything's just negative, negative, negative, negative
and you don't see any positive. >> Not fun. So, genuinely
I mean this. There's no ill will towards anybody. Arch, I wish
you all the best. I >> I picked honestly I picked Zogchow
because both that and Goylop are funny, but I know what Goys
is referencing and I don't understand Zogchow. So, I have plausible
deny these. >> They they just mean the same thing. They're
literally the exact same thing. >> Funny words. Okay. [__]
you. I'm sorry that I'm sorry that bad people made funny terms.
>> It's a poor guys. We keep it positive, guys. We move
on from >> I can't I can't blame a guy for thinking is
funny. Okay. Are you a member? No, I don't watch Nicholas. I
I literally I'm sorry if you think I care. I literally don't
care about what Nicholas says about me. Um unless he's willing
to like engage with me in some way. If he just has me blocked
and he wants to talk, it's like, okay, I I can see that that
is like an incredibly fragile state you're in. Uh I'll let you
handle that in your own way. this and keep on spreading back
good vibes. Never back down, never give up, and have an amazing
rest of your day, guys. >> So, that's it. Yeah, this kid
got [__] cooked. I'm sorry. It's >> Back when
back when him and Quimma were
>> Okay. And then we got the next clip right here. >> We
love a good educational moment, especially as you learn about
it. >> Yeah, dude. I went on the H3 podcast cuz I just
figured that he would do a large unprompted segment just explaining
midgetism to the entire I've created a new term, by the way.
Midgetism. >> Corona virus subreddit. I was like, "Hey,
I'm a filmmaker and educator. I would love to come on and educate
you guys and talk about >> I'm a film making comedian educator
of little people since I know that's such a >> This is
like a Twitter bio for like a
>> He's That was the time stamp by the way. Didn't catch
that, but has to have Zog explained to him again by Dan.
>> You were so innocent. >> GoPop and Zogchow. Go,
>> but I didn't know Zogchow was also a thing, too. These
are like very
>> Yeah, because we're the funniest people and we have
the best. >> No, I don't think that's what it is. >> What
do you have? >> What is Zog? Can you like >> What
is Zog? >> The Zionist occupied government. >> There
was a commentary YouTuber named Zog. Was he like was he anti-Semitic
by >> I don't Am I supposed to know who this is? Should
I go to YouTube?
>> No, he quit. >> We were promoting him. Like, dude,
check out Zog. I didn't know that was like a [__]
slur. >> Well, I mean, it sounds like you're anti-semitic.
I don't uh cringe on main. It's not worth getting into at all.
Uh I think basically he had a take where I was criticizing Willy
Mack and he had to make me like stupid to defend Willie and I
think he just has to continue in that direction without ever
engaging with me directly uh in a way that could reset that.
I think that's just like a commitment he made and he has to keep
going that way. Uh it is what it is.
It's like not worth being upset about even at this point. It's
been like so long totally extricated from like that group of
people. Anyway, >> I'm sorry.
I'm glad that you don't think I'm stupid. Hey, that's cool. >> Sending
stop anti-semitism right now. It's an area mission. Good luck.
We'll see you on the funny papers.
>> All right. Uh Riyle's got a couple other clips for me.
Hold on. >> Uh so the first clip that Queen laughed about
was this one back here. Although this this is from July, so this
has to be like way later. >> Did you see this? So this
is an event that was headlined by Bosch to Platform Zog. And
I think we talked about this on >> I'm in shock. What is
he saying?
There's something wrong with this. What is happening? Is it This
guy's brain is like failing. He's like saying the wrong words.
He means to say something different. I can't tell if he No, I
can't tell which one it is. If he doesn't know what the words
mean or if he's mixing stuff up. Okay. What is he trying to say
there? It's an event PV round. A platform Vosch. No. Event Vos
round. Platform PV. No. Explanations make sense. So I'm like
I feel like maybe he just doesn't know what Zog >> Like
not be paid to be there, but anybody could attend to canvas
after the lolly controversy. And apparently they didn't tell
Zog that like Progressive Victory sent out like America's newest
lollycon to be the spokesman for his like canvasing efforts.
That was another >> Why don't they tell Zog? Why haven't
they told Zog thing that happened? Like they just didn't mention
that. We'll say that was they didn't tell Zog. Does he mean the
Democrats?
He does he think the candidate is called Zog? He doesn't realize
the candidate is Jamal Bowman. He thinks the candidate is called
Zog.
We're going to get Zog the dragon into >> Like this is
after all the Ethan Klein streams and and all the tipster and
the >> I didn't like this though. >> Do you not know
what Zog is? I think that's literally the guy's name. >> It
is. He thinks the candidate is called
He's watching this video and he has literally no idea what the
joke is.
He's playing this video. This This would be such a So, if you
don't remember this video, okay, this video is the one where
Jreg is doing like his whole bit where he's like, "We went to
Canvas because they're an anti It's an anti-ionist candidate,
right, Jamal Bowman." And it's like, "I want to go canvas against
Zog." As in like, "I want to fight against I think it's is it
Richie Torres versus Jamal Bowman? Was that who it was?" because
it's basically like they didn't want Jamal Bowman to win or sorry
they wanted Jamal Bowman to win right >> against some some
Zionist candidate. So, it wasn't Bowman, but I think Apac was
funding Jamal Bowman's opposition, right? And so, it was like
the idea, we're going to go defeat the Apac money, we're going
to go defeat Zog, right? And if you don't know who Zog is, then
the whole bit of Jreg's video where he's talking about how it's
a dragon and he can't say anything more, right? That doesn't
make any sense. None of the video makes any sense. He's seen
this video before and he had no idea
what the joke was. He was completely in the dark. How cool is
that?
>> That's uh that that's weird. That's >> I that's
that feels so weird to me that he was watching this video without
understanding it and just like not talking about it. Like that's
how many times is he just like in the dark on something he's
like faking it? That just
seems crazy to me that you would just be faking um the whole
time. Like fake it till you make it the whole time. Hold on.
There's one more bit here that Riyle linked me. Was this the
Was this just the Dan thing again? This might just be the same
clip. >> The best. What do you have? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. It's the the Zog chow go slop. Okay. All right. Nicholas
not understanding Zog. Unfortunate. Unlucky. Okay. Let's see
here.
Apparently, he figured out what Zog meant and then he asked Dan
later as well to give Dan some power, I guess. All right, we
are moving, I think. No, no, no, no, no. Are we moving or I have
another video here? Are we sure? Are we sure we don't want to
do the Hutch video, guys? Are we positive we don't want to do
a Hutch video? A very long Hutch video on Denim's struggling
to keep up with Hassan's lies.
>> Incredible. Twitch, >> we'll we'll just watch
the hook. We'll we'll see the trailer. The hook for the trailer.
Okay, I'll check out the hook for the trailer. >> Incredible.
Twitch is free, man. It's just free content. So even like the
most maximalist position that people think happened is not even
remotely controversial, isn't it? It's just like >> it's
just such a meme, you know? Like I didn't do it, but if I did,
it's fine. That's literally what is happening in this moment.
>> It doesn't matter anyway because he's already showing
that it's not a shot >> Oh my god. It's not a shot caller,
but if it was, it's fine. But it's not. Unless it was, then it's
fine, but it's not. I think I really can't comment. Yeah, that's
got Yeah, it's pretty uh accurate description of what we just
witnessed. Wait, you could totally have the opinion that like,
oh, if it's a shot color, then I don't care, but I don't think
it is. >> It's a pretty easy It's a pretty easy opinion
to have. >> Uh, this this one piece of footage shows, actually,
excuse you, this one tiny piece of footage shows here that uh
there seems to be something on the back of the color that we
photoshopped in to look like a piece of tape >> that we
photoshopped.
>> Okay, never mind. Denims is Why does How hard is it
to either figure out what you're talking about or not talk? How
hard is it? How hard is it, Denims?
God damn it. >> In to look like a piece of tape is what
she just said. Like we did it live on the stream. We just turned
the contrast up on the screen. That is me. That's me. I did that
[__] Yeah. I pulled his stream up and then I opened
OBS and I just pulled the stream up and I >> I I do think
it's funny now that people are acting like Cutie Cinderella had
inside information instead of just maybe watching like the exact
thing like just watching Ox Twitter or something. Denims is incredibly
stupid. How she got this far is amazing. Uh people can be like
dumb
and calculated, right? So I think Denims can be like dumb when
she analyzes stuff for sure. But she obviously knows how to rage
farm how to like rage bait people, right? She obviously knows
that and sometime maybe that's all that's required in this business.
You know, you just make people upset in just the right way. Didn't
cutie say she went to Hassans. I Cutie said she's been to Hassan,
but what she said was, "Oh, it's this kind of collar."
But I don't know. Oh, I don't know if she was saying that because
she'd seen the caller directly and like looked at it and investigated
it or if she was just following along with like the story
>> here. Hold on. Cuz she Yeah, she does go to Hassan's
for the podcast. Hold on. What? Text is over the character. Oh,
yeah. Well, it would be
okay. Fixed, right? Fixed. Yeah, fixed. Okay, cool. I didn't
even move the character back over today after uh getting my bottom
right corner back. Okay, I put an OBS and then I just turn the
contrast up. That's it. >> Even the e-collars that do shock
are unironically used to train like service dogs and
like hello. You know, that's a bit sus. So, he's denying that
he used a shot collar ostensibly because there would be a lot
of people in his chat that just are principally opposed to shot
collar. So, he's denying that he used the collar cuz he doesn't
want to, you know,
but now we're in a we're in the stage of, you know, but if it
was a shot collar, there would be nothing wrong with that. Like
to a normal person. I >> But he's always done this, right?
He's always said they're effective and they're used to train
dogs. He's literally always
I literally all the time is so based. How can you think this
easy? How can you like listen to this and be so myopic in how
you hear it? I It's like crazy to
Like, and where is it inconsistent in any way? Or are you just
trolling? Cuz maybe maybe you're just trolling. I would love
to know. Okay, you're just uh pretending to be Okay, that's a
good one. Watch the dog training video, Chudwash. I don't know
what that is. You would have to link that to me. Drama 101 needs
to Oh, I've noticed this a lot more. I don't call this out enough.
Yeah, people say like, "Oh, a reasonable person would think this."
And it's like, "Why do you think that?" And they're like, "Well,
a bunch of a bunch of streamers who stream, you know, 70, 80
hours a week." Okay. People streaming 70, 80 hours a week dictating
what's normal to other people who have like never lived a normal
life for their entire the entire time they've been alive. It's
a little it's a little >> I think that would set off some
kind of an alarm bell. That would be like that's a tonal shift
that I don't really quite understand. Again, to a normal person,
the reasonable reaction to that would be like really I there's
like a sequence of events. It's like I don't know. I've seen
somebody pair it's like a satire. I don't know what it is. It's
like a template. It's like it didn't happen, but if it Do I want
to do these racist Republican messages right now? I think I do.
Okay. I think I do.
Okay.
So, if you guys missed it, I'm I'm probably going to switch over
to this and we can There's lots of other stuff we've got tonight,
but I'm going to do the I'm going to do the the actual political
article for today. Okay. We're going to do it right now. Unless
Hold on. Unless drama 101 gets me the training video. God damn
it. Carolyn Quan talks about it. God damn it.
Why can't people just shut up? Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Stop
talking about it. >> I know it probably doesn't matter
to you because you're going to believe what you want to believe
and from the sources you want to believe it from. And that's
why like doesn't matter what I or anyone else says, but it's
not a shock collar. I've seen that collar. I've used that collar
before. I've babysat that dog. Um but again, it it it doesn't
matter. I also said too, you know, I think it was something Hassan
didn't realize in the moment that it was going to be
it was going to end up being a storm like this.
That's Hassan's fault. Okay. If he couldn't I don't believe it.
I don't believe it cuz I am like 1/100th the size of Hassan.
Maybe 1/100th the size of Hassan. No, about a 1/100th. Okay.
See ZZ. See you ZZ. I'm about 1/100th to 1/ 10,000 somewhere
in there the size of Hassan. Okay. And when I have drama going
on in some way or somebody's like talking about me, I get a message
immediately. Hassan Hassan definitely was getting messages from
people and was definitely like getting told to pull up the LSF
thread and seeing that it was like massive. It was already blowing
the up. Hassan had every indication of how big that story was
going to be on the day it was going down. It's it's crazy that
he that anybody would imply otherwise. Okay. Uh, and so he
when it happened and people were mentioning in chat, he just
did not address it because he, as I said,
Emma mod started banning anybody bringing it up, >> didn't
think this was going to be the result. But that person really
typed out XQC the debunker.
Yeah. I mean, I also like I have I have texts between myself
and Boy who was watching Ka after I watched Kaya where I was
like, "Oh, this is the collar." >> Um, you don't have,
you know, she doesn't even wear it most of the time is when she's
in the house. Uh, she has really good recall like her training,
etc., etc. It but it doesn't it does not matter
because
it just, as I said, people just dig their heels in even more.
Um,
it's
>> Okay.
I
like I guess, man, it sucks cuz to me it's like I feel like unless
there's like proof against this, I'm like leaning in this direction
that maybe the the prongs are just gone. But it's like it seems
like if she's used the collar and she's used it to call the dog
back to her.
I don't know, man. But whatever. I I understand people will never
be able to hear Carolyn Quan say something and not feel like
she's just lying
Yeah. See, this is just going to be everybody will run the same
like, "Oh, I can't trust these people."
Um I I just I tend to think that probably she wouldn't just lie,
right? Like I just don't think she would lie outright. I could
see her being like
but I don't think she would outright like basically she could
say, "Oh, well, I think Hassan's like really nice to that dog."
I just don't think she'd say, "I use that color. I know what
that color does. I've used it. I know it's not shocking the dog.
Right. So, I I think it's crazy to like not at all be willing
to to listen to this person. I I don't know. I just don't see
it going that far that she would just outright lie. >> Is
there like a marker?
>> So, someone said, "Look at this time
>> Wait, how do you feel about
collar on
>> You don't need this anymore, right?" >> So, she
tries not to answer it. Okay. There's no writing it maybe. Wait,
have we stream? I think we have, bro. He told us all the way
back.
>> She didn't spell correctly. Unlucky. Okay, now everybody
could just clip this with impunity because you failed to spell
correctly. She spelled with an F instead of a PH. Okay, now all
the Clippers, they're not at all. She tried the Tyler Robinson
strategy. Okay. If you read this, you're gay. Except if you clip
this, you're a
>> No, no, no. You got to get the word
>> How do you feel about the
Here's the deal. I have been to Nissan's house every day for
the past two or every week for the past two years. Okay. >> I
have never seen the dog get shocked.
>> That's my take.
>> Never seen the dog. >> What about the clip though?
What about the clip? >> The clip is insane. Like the clip
looks awful. I He has a vibrating collar and it looks like I've
seen it cuz I Guys, I'm a psychopath. I love dogs. Okay. You've
seen me.
>> Uh-huh. Is that I could have sworn I thought psychopaths
were the ones who torture dogs. I'm a psychopath. I love dogs.
That seems
>> No. No. This is so annoying cuz people have made it
so much better.
>> You're probably right. You clip this to your ped.
>> so what I had to say, I'm in his house. I looked at
the collar. The collar is taped off where I think there would
be
>> There's no zap. There's only there's like there's only
a vibrate function.
>> So, I would agree to that. >> If I didn't have
like my own collar and I put it over like my hoodie and shocked
myself on level 10 and it almost took off my neck. I'm not >> No,
no. There's no shock. Like the electric prongs are taken out
of it. >> But here's my thing, right? >> Like it's
only a vibrate. Like there's a setting for vibrate and there's
a setting for >> That's a fact. That's a fact. >> So
he there's only the like since the prongs are in it, it only
vibrates.
So what you're saying is you >> I I would just wonder if
she listen she could try to say were you there did you see this
caller before this whole controversy? Did you see those prongs
like taken off before the controversy happened or did you know
that >> that whimper couldn't have been due to a vibrate?
I don't think it's anywhere. >> Well,
I'm getting chatter saying this. >> I'm not trying to be
>> I don't have a shot. >> Yeah, I also see teammate
areas here at police shot. I mean, people are just bad cuz they
think look like, yo, they just want the dog in the corner the
whole >> That's what I'm doing. Shot callers are I don't
care if you have a shot. I'm not going to lie. >> I don't
[__] with shot callers. Pretty >> shot.
He was attacking another dog or a human about
>> me and Ron. Me and Ron have a dog named Milo and he
actually got the trainer. >> We should clip this. This
is a time stamp. It's not a It's not a clip. All
Uh, guys, I guess I I need to uh shill. All right, I need to
shill the stream. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead and
follow on every platform. On Twitch and X, it's JSLK_. On Kick,
it's JCLK. You guys are already here. All right, there's a Patreon.
patreon.com/jk.
There's a Discord, discord.gg/jk.
Join the community if you haven't so far. All right, join the
community. >> We have a pretty active politics channel
right now. Um, I'm enjoying that. Okay, >> talking to people
about politics in some Discord. I'm not really in a lot of Discords
right now because my old account's gone. So, I got to just talk
about politics in that Discord if I'm going to. Uh, if you want
to come in, have those conversations, go ahead, join up. If you
really like the content, okay, you want to help the stream go
for longer, we are, I believe, now about five subs away, five
subs away from another two hours on the stream, go ahead. You
can sub on kick. You could also, you know, monetize in a handful
of other ways. You could buy a TTS message, exclamation point,
donate in the chat. We'll give you the links. You could give
me your Twitch Prime. You can sub individually on kick. You can
give subs on kick. You can gift kicks. Okay, we have kicks now.
If you click that little marketplace, that little house at the
bottom of your chat, that'll let you buy kicks. And they're just
basically bits for kick. All right, every dollar goes towards
more time in the stream. We are about $30 away from two more
hours.
So, go ahead, donate, donate, donate. Get the money in, make
the stream go longer. Thank you guys very much for being here.
I appreciate all the support. I appreciate even if you just watch.
All right, thank you guys. And let's continue on. offered to
give him a shot call and he said no.
>> although also Okay. Also, we're we're done with this.
I think I think we made it through. Yeah, it won't matter what
people say. It's all going to just be lies. So, all right. All
right. All right. What about the listeners? I mean, if you're
listening too, I appreciate it. How is the son not got a new
caller at this point? Is he that cheap? I would assume if he
just like So, she was probably trained with this collar or something,
right? It's possible she was trained with his collar and he just
didn't want the shock functionality to work, I guess. I don't
know. It's all weird. Maybe we're not done. I'm getting linked
to another another caller gate
>> I care. So, you've probably been asked, too. People
keep coming in our chat. >> Austin's they go to poor poor
rickety old Austin show who just barely get >> Why are
you hanging out with a dog abuser? I would like to make it clear.
>> I don't believe that Hassan has abused a dog. No, I
also don't believe that either cuz I I have bore witness to how
you treat her and you treat her much better than me.
>> I tell you what, I tell you what, if anything, everybody
should be talking about me. >> I agree. To be fair, >> I
do I will I've been here many, many times. I've never seen, if
you can, you don't have to take my word. I've never seen a shock.
>> I have to admit that >> I've never seen a shock.
Why are you talking like this is a legal document where you're
like >> your honor, I've never seen in my presence when
I'm not around. He's probably shaking the out of >> He's
probably zapping everybody, but I have never seen a zap. >> Yeah,
I've stayed here. >> I think Hassan mostly just doesn't
like addressing these things, so he's probably upset that they're
even talking about it to be honest with you.
>> I I feel like um I like Austin. He's a funny guy. I
promise you Austin Austin wants so badly to make jokes about
this, but he knows that like Hassan will lose it. He knows Hassan's
been going through a rough time, I guarantee you everything I've
seen about Austin, he so badly wants to [__] with
Hassan right now. He I guarantee you he wants to talk about how
like No, I've seen this. No, he knows shock do. He so badly wants
to lean into it, but he knows he can't. >> Yeah. No, >> I
have to admit uh my household is split uh because Farley hates
Ka. >> That's true. So, he was actually super
>> Farley Farley finally likes me cuz he he saw the videos
that was like, "Oh, that getting shot." >> In case you
don't know, Farley's my dog who has little to no training and
>> No, not literally, Cy. Uh Austin used to be a streamer
called Raj and he used to do an Indian accent. Okay. Used to
do an Indian accent. He's basically like uh Kosher Kathy. Okay.
Hey, it's Ka. No.
>> Anyway, Raj Patel. Yes, Raj Patel used to do panels
and stuff.
That's the cell part. Okay, then he is a SAR cell.